- Motherfucker!
- [Creed] Tyler, it's Creed, call me back,
but I'm gonna have them
drop me at American.
You know, I'm flying American.
- This is real bad.
Yo, any updates 'cause I'm like really
struggling to hang out here.
(faint heartbeating)
Man I'm in really bad shape here, bro.
I mean not only am I going to be late,
I'm going to miss the whole draft.
(ominous music)
We need to be way more like yeah,
are we, are we calling,
did we call every private,
like are we full?
Okay, so can we?
Okay, bye.
Let's do a circle.
Let's do one circle.
(ominous thudding)
You got your perspective.
(crowd cheering)
I just want to be happy,
don't you want to be happy?
(slow music)
I need sports cars.
- [Driver] I saw you were driving a uh--
- I don't think most people
know that there's going
to be several, 10, 20,
$30,000 Xion cards to be
had out of $4-5 packs.
That's like a lottery ticket.
That's better than a lottery ticket
because there's other cards.
Dude, I'm telling you right now?
I'm not from around.
Like I'm looking at both of you,
I think, if you actually
bought a certain couple things
I think its like one of
the scariest guaranteed
50 to 100% up-ticket value in 24 months
completely liquid on Ebay
of things I've seen in a very long time.
- [Steven] But you gotta
move on it that quick.
- It's happening right now.
- [Steven] Yeah.
- It's happening right now, you know?
- [Caleb] It's so doable.
- It's unbelievably doable.
- [Caleb] No, if you don't
have say you have under $300.
- Right, you don't have a lot of money.
- [Caleb] $300, yeah, under $100 even.
- No, no, dude this is
like my whole fucking
mantra of like garage
selling and everything.
Like for example, this conversation
was happening in October
I would be like Caleb, please
buy two Giannis rookies.
They're a 170 bucks,
they're going to go up.
They're fucking 450 now.
So, you take that, now you got 1,000.
Now you're sitting here today
and I'm like okay 1,000,
what would be like my number
one thing to do with 1,000?
Right this second 1,000, probably,
I'd probably buy Lucas for
50 a piece, buy 20 of them
and sell them for 75 a piece.
In October when the season
starts, it's just guaranteed.
You might want to take a risk on Darnold.
Baker's a 100 bucks base rookie,
Darnold's 40.
And like that just doesn't
make any sense to me.
So, if Darnold beats Baker
on Monday night football in week two.
I just think like the math
can get to 80 real fast
and then if you have more money,
the real thing to do is
buy these basketball cards
that are about to come out and
try to pull, it's gambling.
You pull a fucking
$5,000 Xion rookie card.
- [Caleb] Hmm.
- Cause it's all one of
one, one of 50 patches,
autos to call it.
It's really happening though,
like all these sneaker
kids are getting into it.
My generation has children now
of the age that can collect.
That's what happened to me
and a lot of other people.
- [Steven] It was interesting,
you said that all the
stuff that we collected
back then is worthless, or
just doesn't have the value.
- What's that?
- [Caleb] The cards
that we used to collect.
- No value.
- Nothing.
You gotta get them greeted
and there's like not a lot of cards worth,
I mean, let me rephrase.
Were you smart enough to
buy 86-87 FLIR basketball?
- No.
- That's it.
That was the thing to buy.
87 Tops.
Every single kid, you know?
- [Caleb] Right.
(soft music)
- This has always been one of the most
classic rides into a city.
To Chicago, right?
(car door clicks)
I'm about to go to the speech in Chicago.
- [Caleb] United Center.
- United Center.
- [Caleb] 9,000 people.
- Damn, I'm gonna be hyped.
(laughing)
9000 people in the United Center.
My opening line might
be fuck Michael Jordan.
Because I hate Michael Jordan.
I fucking hate Michael Jordan.
I hate Michael Jordan.
Literally somebody, this
is not just, this is crazy.
Literally somebody just texted me,
"Just don't look up at the
six championship banners
"and you'll be good.
"Go have fun today in Chicago."
- [Steven] Ah, love it.
- I'm definitely starting
with fuck Michael Jordan now.
- [Caleb] You may want to end with it too.
- Maybe better to end with it.
Don't wanna loose 40 percent
of the crowd before we start.
This happened, we won't
be able to share this.
But, we will in the future.
For the vlog actually just show that part.
And we just edit.
This happened because (bleeping).
(laughing)
This kid is the best.
This is the kid we drafted.
He sneezes, blesses
himself and thanks himself.
- [Man on Phone] Dedication dimmer you all
and care and things.
Bless you, thank you.
(laughs)
- [Caleb] And they say kids
aren't polite these days.
- He's the best.
(upbeat music)
This is good though.
I kind of like, you know me.
Guys I'm so fired up to
met with Andrew Cordle
on the Money Is podcast to
have an authentic conversation.
April 29th, Hulk Hogan,
that's literally what I do.
I know it.
It's really crazy to me that
when I do promo content videos,
I'm literally just
reenacting 1987 wrestling.
If you think The
Undertaker's got a chance,
you've got another thing coming.
(dings)
I eat blueberries like it's my job.
(chewing)
You miss the first 30 I ate.
Look at this.
There used to be blueberries here.
Like it's my job.
- [Caleb] How do you eat so fast?
That's one thing I've noticed.
You just like devour food when you eat.
- 'Cause I'm trying to
accomplish shit out here.
People use fucking lunch and
dinner as an excuse not to do.
I'm on to you fuckfaces.
(laugh) That was a great clip.
- [Steven] Yeah, yeah, that's the best.
- Actually that's like a
great stand alone clip.
(dings)
It's crazy.
- Hey, how you're doing, Gary?
- Great to see you.
- Good to see you, too.
- How've you been?
- Good, good, good.
Did you want a headset, or do you--
- A headset would be great.
- How are you?
- All right, we'll get
you out of here in time.
No problem.
I feel very confident.
- You're already up on
LinkedIn, I love it.
- I have been focused on LinkedIn.
- Yeah.
- You see it?
- Thank you for the tip,
I'm following your lead.
- All right, I'll put this right here.
- Yep.
- How was your flight in?
- It was great.
4:30 wake-up call.
- Wow.
- Yeah, forgot a beanie today
for the first time ever.
So like struggled, like sleeping,
'cause I need the beanie to cover my eyes.
- [Caleb] Really, what's what?
- Yeah.
- Interesting.
- That's how I sleep.
The reason I wear beanie is
because on the flight I cover my eyes.
That's why I wear it in the summer too.
- [Caleb] Huh.
- Uh-huh, that's the fun
fact of the day, ping!
(dings)
- We're on the same page.
- Good?
- Good.
- [Woman] We are in the United Center.
- Chicago, go time.
I have to go on stage,
30 minutes of complete and utter passion.
- [Woman] GaryVee, come
on guys, let's hear it.
(applause)
- [Woman] Get on your feet
and let's rake it up for GaryVee.
(upbeat music)
- What's up, Chicago?
The single biggest thing, in
my opinion, that the majority
of the people in this
room are doing wrong.
This is number one.
I believe that 98% of the
people in this arena right now,
buy too much dumb shit.
(crowd laughter)
I have become crazy fascinated
as I've lived my life
of trying to understand
why the fuck so many
of my parents immigrant's
friends, other immigrants,
and just immigrants in general
have a disproportionate success rate
in the framework of America.
And I finally figured it out.
They're not smarter.
It's not even necessarily
that they work harder.
It's that they come to America,
and they buy nothing stupid
for 15 fucking years.
They just live like shit,
buy nothing, save money,
buy a business and move on.
The level of insecurity that
is permeating this country,
so that people end up buying
cars and houses and clothes
that they can't afford to impress people
that they don't even like
is the great epidemic in our society.
(crowd applause)
I get to say this from truth.
I lived my 20s, all my
20s, 22 to 29, my 20s
in the shitty fucking apartment
in Springfield, New Jersey.
I didn't buy any fucking clothes,
I didn't have swag fucking sneakers.
I didn't come around no fucking vacations.
I just fucking worked and saved the money.
And I was building a
business for my parents,
not even for myself.
So, when I tell people to be patient,
it's easy 'cause I lived it.
I don't stand up here ever
talking about shit that
I didn't actually do first.
(quick applause)
And so, if you are not pumped,
if you're not like loving life,
before you try to figure
out the hook or the secret
or if you think Tony's gonna
rejigger your fucking brain.
Or I'm gonna give you some fucking secret
to do on fucking Instagram
that's gonna change everything.
Before you think about that,
go home and look at your
fucking credit card bill
and stop buying dumb shit.
(crowd applause)
We have to fucking talk about this.
That's the game.
Please, wake up.
I love you, Chicago.
(applause, crowd roaring)
Wake up, Chicago!
Way up there!
I see you back there!
I see you up there!
(crowd cheering)
Love you, too.
Thank you!
(applause)
(laughing)
- [Woman] What an amazing morning.
All right, stay where you are because--
- [Caleb] Can we do a quick intro to it?
- Hi guys, I just took
the stage in Chicago,
swipe up to see what I just did.
- [Camera Man] Perfect,
and can you intro it
just for the video?
- Hey guys, just gave a great talk
in Chicago at the United Center.
A lot of mind stuff, some new stuff,
a lot of new stuff came out, Caleb.
I'm super excited about it.
I hope you enjoy it.
Leave a comment below
on what new stuff really
caught your attention especially if you're
a hardcore consumer of my content.
- [Camera Man] Perfect.
- That's right now like
the best kept secret like
I just partnered up with Tony Robertson-
- Dude, you'll appreciate this.
I was the best kept secret for 11 years.
Like, think about this dude.
You were shot in the fucking head.
You're so lucky to even have this at bat.
It's what I said up there.
I know you're hungry, right?
- Yeah.
- And you want to be not
the best-kept secret.
You want to be on.
- 100%.
- But I'm telling you
right now, the best era
is when you're the, you
know, best-kept secret.
- Yeah.
- Enjoy the fuck out of this process.
I loved a little bit deep-down
being underestimated.
- Yeah, 100%.
- You know, you know.
Just enjoy this
because in five, seven, nine
years you're gonna be known,
and then it's gonna be a different thing.
Enjoy this process.
You're young as fuck.
- Awesome, thank you, Gary.
- You got it, bro.
- We'll follow security.
- Gary, there's Kevin.
Have you guys met Gary?
- We have.
- How are you?
Good to see you.
- Kevin, great to see you.
- Great, good, good, good.
- [Man] On the right, on the right.
- Sorry.
Hello.
What up, everyone.
(cheering)
- Gary, I have one question for you.
What are your thoughts
on the New York Jets
draft picks last night?
(laughing)
- I love the pick.
I don't know if you saw
this, but I just tweeted it.
The kid we picked, Quinnen Williams,
was doing an interview yesterday.
He sneezes during an interview,
he says god bless you to himself,
and then thanks himself
for saying god bless you.
(crowd laughter)
That's when I knew we
picked the right guy.
(dings)
- All right, I think that's it, guys.
(crowd murmuring)
- We are out of here, thank you.
Please give these guys a huge--
(crowd clamoring)
- Mine's delayed, but I asked
them to find a different one.
- [Steven] Sorry, not smart.
- Yeah, did they not hit you up?
Did they not hit you up for logistics?
Maybe they're handling it.
I said to talk to you during my Q&A.
(fan screaming)
Let's stop for a selfie for these guys.
They're making a real effort.
- Nice to meet you, man.
- Nice to meet you.
How are you?
- Fine.
- Oh my god.
Man, I was waiting 40 minutes over there.
(wind blowing)
- All right, fellas, take care.
- Thanks man, love you.
Thank you, guys, take care.
(laughs)
- Go ahead.
- [Caleb] Rappers come out
with their day one homies,
film-makers come out with
their day one homies.
You have a lot of people
that you've been close to
that are friends and family
that have worked with you.
How have you gone about
accomplishing that?
I think there's a lot of people
that would like to do the same.
But there's, I think, complexity
to working with people
that you're that close to.
- (sigh) It's about
expectations of day one homies.
You know, I've been
successful with working,
you know, it's funny,
when you're talking about day one homies,
I remember thinking about Joe and Moose
and a couple of my college friends
who decided not to come to
Wine Library after college.
But then we invited Brandon
did come, he was high school.
And then obviously Matt Sinemar, like AJ,
and all of AJ's friends.
Wine Library, obviously when
we go to the next chapters,
there will be a lot of people
like now that people know
like Danny Kay or Marcus
or whoever it may be.
Emily McDounugh, whoever it might be.
The thing that when you
talk to athletes or rappers
or anybody about day one homies,
it plays into an interesting game because
it grows completely, my
advice I'm about to give
is a complete contradiction to
put more positive people around you
and cut out people who don't bring value.
What is very cliche is
that when you have a star
an earner, the engine, the thing.
There's always people
around it that are day one
that were incredibly instrumental in
being emotionally there and friends
and maybe not even instrumental,
a lot of times it's just serendipity.
But now that we're here,
think they believe,
the people around the
earner, the North Star,
think they made it.
(finger snaps)
Our guy, our gal made it.
Now we're here.
But for that person, the
process has just begun.
Got it?
And what happens is a lot of friction.
And you have the cliché
things that we've all seen
in like TV shows and I've heard stories of
like the hanger honors
and it's like Ludacris.
But then there's the one
that we don't talk about.
The one that's like, you
know like, the one that you
see on TV shows and movies
is like cliche, right?
Layin' around, just enjoying the life.
You know, everybody watched Entourage.
I think the person that
is not talked about enough
is actually your homie
who's really trying.
Who just doesn't have talent
as the machine gets bigger,
as that person gets bigger.
(music)
What Lebron's luxury
in that scenario is the
enormous talent and
capability of Maverick.
- [Caleb] Correct.
- He's the real guy, you know?
- [Friend] You get that one person.
- One of the most interesting
things for me in watching
the business culture
over the last 20 years...
My plane's massively delayed.
I've gotta do something else.
I might go private.
So give me, I'm on a call,
I just want you guys to
know what's going on.
- [Caleb] Okay.
- Motherfucker.
- [Creed] Tyler, it's Creed, call me back.
But I'm gonna have him
drop me at American.
You know I'm flying American.
- Yup, yup.
- [Caleb] Maybe I'll just stay in the car.
- Are you on Delta with me?
- [Caleb] We're on the same flight, yeah.
It's like back to five
or something, right?
- Yeah, I'm dead.
I've got work to do around the draft.
This is real bad.
(beeping)
Okay.
Okay, keep updating me.
We're like circling around the airport
and I don't wanna hold them up too long.
So, let's get them some
solutions ASAP, okay?
Okay, bye.
Let's go to the Delta terminal
and then we'll just sit like this.
If we can.
Flight issues.
Gonna miss the draft.
Chicago to New York is always challenging.
Not good.
We'll see.
Team's working on it.
We have to go around.
Can you hold on?
They're forcing you right now?
You know what, let me call you right back.
Try to buy one minute,
try to buy one minute.
Yeah, you can start rolling a little bit
because we can go past her.
Yo, any updates 'cause I'm like
really struggling to hangout here.
Man, I'm in really bad shape here, bro.
I mean not only am I gonna be late,
I'm gonna miss the whole draft.
We need to be way more, like yeah, are we?
Are we calling every, did
we call every private,
like are we full?
Okay, so can we?
Okay, bye.
Let's do a circle.
Let's do one circle.
My 5:00PM flight is now
leaving before the four's
because the four's are now seven's.
God fucking dammit, I'm
gonna miss the draft.
(sigh)
Yup, thank you.
So, you're doing your thing.
Okay, thank you, bye.
- [Driver] It has to be a couple times
before we have to go around again.
- I think I'm gonna go to Delta right now.
That's unfortunately where I think I'm at.
(blows raspberry)
All right, plane issues
are gonna make miss
half of the fucking
draft so, there's that.
But, all prospective baby.
As much as that fucking sucks
and even though it's one of
my few days of enjoyment,
it's a lot better than being dead.
(gentle music)
It's cool, right?
Especially when you can't see?
- [Steven] Yeah, all of it, yeah.
- That'll be cool.
- [Steven] Yeah.